all right
Julia you can change them on the floor
foreign
yeah
what do they call you
Thomas
do you have a family
a wife
someone to think about
mama
then remember
this is just work
same as you always done
just work
God is with us
how can you say that to him
where where is he
but why has he not set you free
or has he
are not in these
but then stand up
stand up go stand up stand up and I
praise your God for all he has done for
you for all of us
you
God is not with you
he is nowhere
he sends that fool to to tell us about
his word
to be a good slave
to to be obedient to your masters
is that what God says to you
God says many things
I do not know why
God shows himself to some people
and not to others
but if you do not know him
[Music]
I will pray for you